dire de vous recevoir en place tient
aujourd'hui de rappeler à terme de
souvenirs pour une petite partie toute
petite partie des communes à nous est
commune je regarde moi même un excellent
souvenir et je garderai un bon souvenir
de cette émission va déterminer les
caisses on la retrouve en rediffusion la
retrouve en replay aussi sur les réseaux
sociaux qui diffuse la radio on la
retrouve sur le site internet arte
france point tv merci à tous à très
bientôt
[Musique]
l'afrique regorge de richesses mais ne
représentent que 3% du pib mondial en
2021 pourquoi l'afrique hors transports
un petit peu ces matières premières le
problème n'est pas technique c'est un
manque de prise de conscience collectif
des dirigeants africains c'est tout un
ensemble de chaînes des gens qui vont
s'accaparer au pouvoir et la richesse
qui valent la gabégie des hommes d'état
ont l'associent à ce système aussi de la
françafrique la françafrique tout le
monde est au courant maintenant il
s'agit d'un club l'ésotérique de pouvoir
d'argent pour ensemble trouver un
système de rente est par définition de
nombreuses distributions aux populations
il s'agit de venir prendre à la source
quelque chose le problème de fond c'est
curieux c'est la façon d'en temps le
point
[Musique]
cinquante quatre mille manifestants
partout en france cet après midi selon
le ministère de l'intérieur mobilisation
en baisse par rapport à la semaine
dernière de nouveaux rassemblements un
peu partout en france pour dénoncer le
pass vaccinale antico vide
le texte pourrait être applicable à la
fin de la semaine prochaine sur le
président de la commission des lois à
l'assemblée nationale où nos projets de
loi pourrait être adopté définitivement
dès demain
[Musique]
balle de match attendu s'est tenu par
novak djokovic d audience en référé en
lieu devant une cour fédérale pour
savoir si numéro un mondiale de tennis
expulsé l'australie et ce à la veille du
début du premier tournoi du grand chelem
de l'année qui débute lundi à melbourne
le serbe a été renvoyé en rétention
administrative après l'annulation de
zain pour la deuxième fois par le
gouvernement australien
[Musique]
après la vague épidémique la vague des
scandales aborigènes
mais fragilisée par les apéros du
vendredi à darwin street la résidence du
premier ministre britannique
manquement aux règles sanitaires après
les soirées de noël et le parti gates
les appels à la démission du
conservateur également critiqué au sein
même de sa majorité se multiplient
[Musique]
très bonne soirée à toutes et à tous
très heureux de vous retrouver sur arte
france pour un nouveau point complet sur
l'actualité le pass en berne les
opposants en colère alors que 560 mille
personnes perdent aujourd'hui leur pass
sanitaires faute de rappel vaccinal
antico vide 54 mille personnes ont
manifesté une nouvelle fois cet après
midi dans de nombreuses villes en france
un énième samedi de protestation pour
dire non au pass vaccinale actuellement
examiné par les sénateurs plusieurs
rassemblements à paris certains statique
d'autres en mouvement comme celui du
chef de file des patriotes florian
philippot encore celui des gilet jaune
guillemin aussi a suivi cette journée de
mobilisation parisienne
ils étaient quelques milliers à composer
le cortège de gilet jaune qui a défilé
dans la capitale davantage encore au
rassemblement de florian philippot c'est
le deuxième samedi consécutif à
connaître un rebond de la mobilisation
depuis le début de la contestation cet
été un rebond notamment due à la
déclaration des manuels macron je vous
rappelle les propos du président de la
république tenus il y a une dizaine de
jours environ les non-vaccinés j'ai très
envie de les emmerder fin de citation
des mots encore très présent à l'esprit
des manifestants aujourd'hui est à la
source de cette mobilisation nationale
il y avait bien entendu l'actualité
sanitaire avec ce fameux pass vaccinale
dont le texte était à l'étude ce samedi
au sénat passe vaccinale qui devrait
entrer en vigueur très vraisemblablement
fin de semaine prochaine voire au début
de la semaine suivante et je vous
propose d'écouter certains des
manifestants présents aujourd'hui nous
aussi on emmerde voilà la réponse qu'on
y donnera à mâcon ont leurs nerfs
d'aussi également ils respectent pas le
peuple recueillir respectent pas les
citoyens je puis pouvoir prendre le
train j'ai plus pouvoir aller voir ma
famille comme je veux
les restos les bars et tout ça je m'en
fous un peu voilà mais surtout aller
voir les gens que j'aime il veut diviser
je pense qu'il veut diviser les français
et c'est ce qu'il est en train de faire
en fait sans elle al'impression un petit
peu d'être beaucoup d'être des
prisonniers on a l'impression d'être
coupable alors qu'on n'a rien fait
on a l'impression d'être des pestiférés
alors qu'on est pas malade voilà c'est
comme un extrait c'est quand même
extrêmement grave je suis pas pour la
contrainte je suis pour l'envoie là je
veux quand je veux convaincre les gens
moi je juge je suis partisan de que
voilà que les gens se vaccine d'autant
plus les gens à risque voilà après après
maintenant je veux jouer contre
l'obligation voilà c'est surtout ça qui
me motive et toujours dans l'actualité
sanitaire de ce samedi il y avait bien
entendu la désactivation de nombreux
spas sanitaire plusieurs dizaines de
milliers au moins très certainement l'un
des motifs de la colère à l'origine de
la mobilisation aujourd'hui à paris mais
aussi dans toute la france la semaine
passée plus de cent cinq mille
manifestants se sont rassemblés malgré
une forte baisse de participation
aujourd'hui selon beauvau notre
éditorialiste et sociologue michel fize
estime que la contestation est en voie
de s'intensifier
la france va mal et les français sont en
colère et de plus en plus en colère et
on a l'impression que le mouvement se
solidifie se cristallisent au fil au fil
des semaines tant le mécontentement et
les rancoeurs se sont accumulés au fil
des mois et des mois avec pour point de
départ évidemment le mouvement des gilet
jaune en novembre 2018 donc aujourd'hui
on est à un tournant et aussi peut-être
un tournant dans la balance entre
sécurité et liberté depuis des mois la
balance a semblé plutôt penché du côté
de la sécurité sanitaire aujourd'hui
elle pencherait plutôt avec l'aide
d'ailleurs des tribunaux du côté des
libertés un peu l'exemple aussi de ce
qu'on voit dans d'autres pays où on
dessert les étreintes sur le citoyen et
l'étreinte des parlementaires au sujet
du pass vaccinale ne se desserre pas
après avoir été adoptée cette nuit en
deuxième lecture par les députés le
projet de loi repasse devant le sénat
ils étaient examinés tout à l'heure au
palais du luxembourg
mais d'après la présidente de la
commission des lois de l'assemblée
nationale yene brawl peavey le texte je
cite pourrait être applicable à la fin
de la semaine prochaine l'assemblée
nationale qui aura le dernier mot demain
est une candidate à l'élection
présidentielle et contre le passage
vaccinale il s'agit de marine le pen qui
s'engagent dans la dernière ligne droite
de sa campagne la chef de file du
rassemblement national vient de dévoiler
une vidéo mise en scène à l'endroit même
où emmanuel macron avait célébré sa
victoire cinq ans auparavant devant le
musée du louvre qui indique ne pas avoir
donné son accord pour le tournage de
cette séquence extraits
c'est ici il ya cinq ans qu'a commencé
un quinquennat qu emmanuel macron
présenté comme ambitieux dans ses
projets lumineux dans ses moyens et
heureux dans ses choix cinq ans après la
promesse de cette confiance qui oblige
de cette bienveillance exhibé de cette
réconciliation proclamé de cette
humilité affirmé de ce respect pour
chacun se sont évanouis tout comme
l'engagement d'un monde plus sûr de
liberté défendu de perspectives de
croissance pour reprendre les termes du
discours de monsieur macro ce soir du 7
mai 2010 est le temps venu au moment des
grandes décisions soyez sûr que ma
volonté ne fléchira pas que ma main ne
tremblera pas et que je serai digne des
responsabilités que vous m'avez confiées
autre prétendante à l'élection
présidentielle christiane taubira qui a
officialisé tout à l'heure sa
candidature à moins de trois mois du
premier tour la gauche compte désormais
six principaux candidats une annonce
officielle de l'ancien ministre de la
justice fait à lyon à l'occasion d'un
rassemblement militant pour l'union de
la gauche l'ex garde des sceaux sous le
quinquennat de françois hollande dit
vouloir participer à une primaire de la
gauche ce que refuse ses concurrents a
soumis notamment jean luc mélenchon ou
encore écologiste yannick jadot
manifestation anti passe vaccinale donc
en france aujourd'hui et protestations
anti restrictions sanitaires demain à
amsterdam aux pays bas où les règles
sont assouplies d'aujourd'hui commerce
celle de sport et coiffeurs ouvre mais
une partie de la population se dit
exaspéré cela ne godin avec maxime
hébert un allègement façon de
mécontentement à partir de ce samedi les
pays bas retrouvent le chemin d'une vie
normale annonce faite par le premier
ministre aux néerlandais donc non
vraiment un risque nous nous faisons un
très grand pas je pense à un risque
responsable au cours des dix prochains
jours nous examinerons exactement ce que
nous pouvons apprendre de la situation à
l'étranger et ce que nous pouvons en
apprendre ici au pays d'arlanc un risque
calculé voire politique car le
renforcement de ces restrictions le 19
décembre avait suscité la crispation
d'une bonne partie de la population qui
a passé noël et nouvel an qu'on finit la
nouvelle est donc accueilli avec
soulagement même si certains
établissements comme les cinémas les
bars ou encore les restaurants resteront
encore fermée jusqu'au 25 janvier
nous sommes contents que les magasins
soient ouverts aujourd'hui vous voyez ça
nous avons des masques nous gardons la
distance de sécurité les bars les
restaurants devraient également être
ouverts si nous respectons des règles
nous sommes vraiment contents
c'était une période misérables et
difficile amen
nous étions occupés avec toutes sortes
de choses comme le click and collect la
raison à domicile la vente de vidéos
[Musique]
tellement de choses différentes pour
maintenir les revenus
c'est très difficile ça ne semble pas
juste en ce moment
les premiers blocages étaient logiques
j'étais d'accord avec eux mais ça ne me
semble plus juste
elle les annonces du premier ministre
n'ont donc pas concat et tout le monde
comme il y à un mois au moment de la
mise en place de ces mesures des heurts
ont éclaté entre la police et des
manifestants à la marque route eu de son
côté continue de mettre en garde la
population contre de nouvelles
contaminations
décontamination qui pourrait bientôt
atteindre les 80 milles par jour
[Applaudissements]
novak djokovic plus que jamais dans le
filet de la justice australienne numéro
un mondiale de tennis est de nouveau
placé en rétention à melbourne alors que
des audiences ont lieu ce soir dans une
cour fédérale en jeu sa participation à
l'open d'australie qui débute dans la
nuit de dimanche à lundi ou bien son
exclusion pour cause de non vaccination
anti qu'ovide thibault jana
novak djokovic ont mené sous bonne
escorte symbole du nouveau revers
infligé au numéro un mondiale de tennis
le serbe a été renvoyé en rétention
administrative ce samedi à melbourne
conséquence d'une nouvelle annulation de
son visa a annoncé par le ministre
australien de l'immigration à l'ex ocpt
j'ai exercé mon pouvoir en vertu de
l'article 133 c de la loi sur
l'immigration pour annuler le visa
détenus par monsieur novak djokovic pour
des raisons de santé de bon ordre au
motif qu'il était dans l'intérêt public
de le faire le gouvernement morrison
s'est fermement engagé à protéger les
frontières de l'australie en particulier
en ce qui concerne la pandémie de
cofidis mme novak djokovic qui a admis
ne pas avoir rempli correctement sa
déclaration d'entrée en australie a été
placée dans un lieu tenu secret dans
l'attenté d'une décision judiciaire sur
son cas un traitement dénoncé par le
président serbe qui a fustigé l'attitude
des autorités australiennes sache trop
pourquoi le maltraiter vous pourquoi
vous en prenez voulons seulement à lui
mais aussi à sa famille et à toute la
nation éprise de liberté est fier ce
si vous vouliez interdire à novak
djokovic de remporter un dixième trophée
à melbourne pourquoi ne l'avez vous pas
renvoyer immédiatement
pourquoi ne lui avez vous pas dit qu'il
était impossible d'obtenir un visa pour
votre pays
novak nous sommes à tes côtés aleksandar
vucic avait déjà apporté son soutien au
joueur de tennis dès le début de l'
affaire qualifiant de chasse aux
sorcières politique le traitement
infligé au numéro un mondial le futur de
novak djokovic est désormais entre les
mains de la cour fédérale australienne d
audience en référé sont prévues ce
samedi avant une décision finale dans la
soirée sur une éventuelle participation
à l'open d'australie à 34 ans le serbe
espère encore briguer un 10e titre à
melbourne et une 21e victoire en grand
chelem qui ferait de lui le tennisman le
plus titré de l'histoire son entrée en
lice est quant à elle toujours prévue
lundi
une manifestation aujourd'hui à londres
royaume uni contre l'immigration
illégale une protestation contre un
projet de loi sur le point d'être
approuvée ce cortège s'est jointe un
autre défilé celui opposant boris
johnson qui cumule les déconvenues suite
au scandale à des soirées privées
organisées hot and housing street la
résidence du premier ministre
britannique le conservateur de 57 ans et
avoue fragilisé par les apéros du
vendredi nouveau manquement aux règles
sanitaires après les soirées de noël et
le parti gate les appels à sa démission
se multiplient
malgré ses excuses sa cote de popularité
est au plus bas plusieurs noms circulent
déjà pour le remplacer maxime vers
c'est peut-être là faire de trop pour
boris johnson visé par une enquête
appelé à démissionner par l'opposition
comme au sein même de son propre parti
le premier ministre britannique vit peut
être ses dernières heures à downing
street en cause les révélations sur une
garden party organisée en mai 2020 alors
que tout le royaume est confiné et
soumis aux règles sanitaires
c'est absolument dégoûtantes cet homme
est un charlatan est un menteur c'est ce
que nous avons eu comme premier ministre
il n'y a pas deux façons de le dire
c'est une honte
je pense que c'est assez choquant car
cela montre beaucoup d'hypocrisie dans
notre direction et le parti tory
vraiment divisé en ce moment donc je
pense que boris sera parti dans les deux
prochains mois
je ne suis pas sûr pour être honnête
peut être riche je pense qu'il serait
bon mais vous savez après un tel
scandale peut-être qu'un changement de
gouvernement est nécessaire
grand favori pour le poste en cas de
départ de johnson riches issus nac
ministre des finances député depuis 2015
tu n'as qu'a été saluée pour ses mesures
en faveur de la sauvegarde de l'emploi
pendant la crise sanitaire
relativement jeune en politique sa
personnalité est à l'opposé de celle
d'un boris johnson près d'un
conservateur sur deux considère reste
une ac comme un meilleur premier mini
selon un sondage révélé par sky news
dimanche dernier très commentée
également outre manche son appui timorés
à johnson huile 11 heures après que le
premier ministre a dû s'expliquer devant
les parlementaires
j'ai été en visite toute la journée pour
continuer à travailler sur notre plan
pour l'emploi ainsi que pour rencontrer
des députés afin de discuter de la
situation énergétique le premier
ministre a eu raison de présenter ses
excuses et je soutiens sa demande de
faire preuve de patience pendant que
sous grez mène son enquête
l'autre favorite se nomme liste run la
ministre des affaires étrangères âgé de
46 ans et très populaire parmi les
conservateurs d'abord en faveur du
maintien du royaume uni dans lieux
trucks s'était ensuite rangé du côté des
briques sitter elle avait conclu
plusieurs accords commerciaux post break
6 deux autres poids lourds du parti tory
serait également dans la course free
type at elle la plus conservatrice des
députés et michael gove ancien
journaliste est populaire dans les
régions défavorisées du royaume pour
renverser johnson considéré comme un
mauvais premier ministre par cette
britannique sur dix un vote de défiance
au sein du parti conservateur suffirait
enfin dernière option pour les torts is
maintenir johnson au pouvoir contre
vents et marées pour cela il faudrait
calmer le jeu attendre le rapport de l'
enquête avec comme juge de paix les
élections locales du printemps prochain
et une autre réaction celle du parti
travailliste est son chef de file qui
errent starmer dénonce l'incapacité de
boris johnson a gouverné
ce pays est confronté à d'énormes défis
et nous avons un premier ministre qui
est absent ils se cachent littéralement
en ce moment et il est incapable de
diriger c'est pourquoi j'ai conclu qu'il
devait partir et bien sûr son départ
serait un avantage pour le parti
travailliste mais en fait c'est
maintenant dans l'intérêt national qu'il
parte bon c'est très important que le
parti conservateur fait le nécessaire et
se débarrasse de lui
même
incertitude au mali au lendemain d'une
manifestation de masse qui a réuni
plusieurs milliers de personnes à bamako
pour protester contre les dernières
sanctions internationales une
mobilisation à l'appel de l'armée au
pouvoir qui annonce un plan de riposte
contre les mesures punitives de la
cedeao des sanctions ouest africaine
soutenue et approuvée par l'union
européenne qui sévit à son tour amaya
souple elle
l'appelle de la jante à manifester à
raisonner place de l'indépendance à
bamako des milliers de maliens se sont
rassemblés dans la capitale en
brandissant les couleurs vertes jaunes
et rouges du pénis un symbole fort pour
protester contre les sanctions de la
cedeao et de lune et soutenir l'armée au
pouvoir et les maliens sont sortis dans
toutes les localités et et moi je pense
que ça c'est pour montrer à la planète
entière que les autorités son suivi et
elles sont soutenues par un flot peuple
comme quoi il n'ya pas qu'elles sont des
peintures le soutient l'agente militaire
s'est propagé à travers de nombreuses
villes du pays le premier ministre a
salué la mobilisation populaire et le
soutien de longue date de certains
alliés
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
toujours
ma vie
c'est
[Musique]
s'il ne souhaite pas entrer dans un bras
de fer avec la cédéao le chef de la
junte à 6000 gates a annoncé un plan de
riposte contre ces sanctions ce vendredi
l'embargo commercial et les gels
budgétaires de la communauté des états
de l'ouest africain ont reçu le soutien
de l'union européenne et ses pays
membres ont également durement condamné
l'armée au pouvoir
il souhaite malgré tout maintenir une
présence militaire pour lutter contre le
terrorisme mais pas à n'importe quel
prix selon jean yves le drian
il a exprimé cette position lors d'une
réunion informelle à brest des ministres
européens des affaires étrangères qui
souhaite que la transition du pouvoir se
fasse dans des délais plus brefs que
cela l'oci et puisque là la raison qui
est invoquée par la junte
d'allonger la transition
jusque durée de cinq ans la raison tient
à vos caisses et des raisons de sécurité
on ne peut pas procéder à des votes
parce que nous sommes pas en sécurité
je pense que si on est en sécurité pour
manifester on doit sûrement être en
sécurité pour voter la tenue d'un
calendrier électoral acceptables
pourrait apaiser les tensions entre la
communauté internationale et le mali
plongé dans une crise sécuritaire et
politique depuis de nombreuses années
l'embargo commercial pourrait de plus
mettre à mal l'économie d'un des pays
les plus pauvres du monde
drissa 40 bayal président du collectif
malien de belgique ils dénoncent des
sanctions qui touchent ton premier chef
la population selon lui les mali est un
embargo à toi une bonne partie notamment
du centre et c est un embargo depuis
maintenant plus de cinq ans ou les
villages ont été brûlées des gens ont
été tués des femmes ont été violées des
vols ont été commis et c'est donc là la
procès que le peuple est désormais et
résilients et dire que de toute façon on
ne peut pas il vient ne peut arriver des
piles que ce qui se passe
depuis cinq ans donc effectivement il
faut pas quand même c'est vrai que un
pays continental comme les mali
n'est pas totalement il est très
difficile de s'en sortir comme ça quand
les frontières sont fermées parce que il
ya quand même beaucoup de produits
d'importation qui viennent par exemple
du sénégal et d'autres pays écoutiez
c'est pas facile mais c'est qui ce passe
en fait le malien se sentent attaqués
dans leur dignité donc c'est plutôt un
combat des dignités qui est en train de
se de se faire voir actuellement
autres pays africains l'ethiopie où les
combats font rage dans la région
dissidente du tigre et au moins cent
huit civils ont été tués depuis le début
de l'année dans des frappes aériennes
l'onu attribuent ces attaques aux forces
fédérales depuis plus d'un an cette zone
stratégique est le théâtre d'un conflit
armé entre le gouvernement et les
anciennes autorités locales issues du
front de libération du peuple du tigré
un parti qui a dirigé le pays pendant
près de 30 ans
et pour terminer ce journal on parle de
gastronomie 69 restaurants à moscou ont
été choisies pour la toute première
édition du guide michelin en octobre
dernier le célèbre livre a été
impressionné par la diversité
du patrimoine gastronomique russe une
cuisine authentique à base de produits
locaux de grande qualité verhaeghe of
man est allé à la rencontre de la grande
cuisine russe
celui qui a mis les pieds à au sco après
les années 2000 c'est très bien que la
scène gastronomique russe est très
appétissante et l'arrivée du guide
michelin dans la capitale russe n'a fait
que le confirmer pour un gourmand avisé
moscou vaut absolument le détour david
hemmerlé chef français du restaurant
grands crus fait partie des sept chefs
d'établissement moscovite ayant décroché
une étoile au michelin s'appuyant sur sa
grosse expérience dans des restaurants
étoilés icaunais mouscou depuis une
trentaine d'années à ses yeux le
véritable essor de la cuisine russe date
de 2014 et des sanctions alimentaire que
la russie a imposé à réponse aux
sanctions occidentales après 2014 on a
commencé à travailler des produits
locaux il ya dix ans il y avait pas de
saint-jacques russe à moscou et puis
maintenant on en a partout de sakhaline
donc il ya eu je pense comme annoncé
c'est mieux léa les russes qui ont pris
les choses en main et puis qui ont
commencé à voile à écrire un peu leur
leur tendance quoi avec les idées les
idées européennes nordiques etc
sciatiques un peu de mélange et tout et
puis voilà et puis malgré les crises
moscou continue de d'évoluer le progrès
c'est donc non je pense qu'ils arrivent
au bon moment le destin fait bien les
choses le maire développe puis à moscou
s'est rénové depuis ces vingt dernières
années quand même donc maintenant on est
prêt à recevoir toute cette clientèle
internationale et nationale mais qui
arrivent de toute la russie pour
découvrir la gastronomie la gastronomie
la culture gastronomique à moscou la
chefferie catilina lokchina est persuadé
que le guide michelin ne va pas
s'arrêter à moscou et qui va explorer
d'autres virus
seule femme de la sélection il était
riina le china est propriétaire de son
propre établissement paix logique elle a
été également décoré d'une étoile verte
michelin pour son approche durable mais
aussi sa conception zéro déchet
tout d'abord nous avons un grand pays un
pays intéressant et beaucoup d'étrangers
pense que la cuisine russe se limite à
la cuisine soviétique avec de la
mayonnaise de la salade russe le hareng
sous sa forme le bois est un site suisse
allez y est c'est l'euphorie des bourses
et la [ __ ] est à 110 léonard est
traduit en réalité nous avons de grandes
traditions tu as notamment en matière de
fermentation parce que chez nous l'hiver
est long et pour l'hiver nos ancêtres
faisait des salaisons de plantes de
champignons il m'arrivait et faisait
sécher de l'avion
quant aux jumeaux berezutski il constate
qu'un bouleversement est à l'oeuvre en
russie ces derniers temps car les russes
se rendent compte qu'ils ont eux aussi
des produits de très grande qualité sur
leur sol et ont donc cessé de vénérer
tout ce qui vient de l'étranger le
restaurant des deux frères le twins
garden est l'un des deux établissements
de la capitale avoir reçu deux étoiles
au michelin
le monde s'intéresse à la cuisine russe
pour le moment bien sûr elle n'est pas
aussi bien promues que par exemple la
cuisine italienne mais comme dit le
proverbe russe on met du temps pour
atteler mais on prend de la vitesse
après
et donc vous savez il ya un intérêt pour
la cuisine russe et on associe quand
même l'arrivée du guide michelin
justement à cet intérêt pour la cuisine
russe pour les traditions russes pour
les produits alimentaires russe
cela va-t-il changer c'est déjà en train
de changer vous savez ça avait déjà
commencé avant je crois que l'arrivée du
guide michelin est une conséquence de
l'intérêt pour la cuisine russe pour les
restaurants russe cela a donné une
grande impulsion au développement
la pandémie de colis 19 alain je me
restreins à les itinéraires touristiques
mais une fois cette plaie refermer
moscou sera prête à accueillir de
nouveaux les voyageurs internationaux et
pas seulement avec le boersch et les
blés ni et bon appétit bien sûr c'est la
fin de cette édition merci de votre
fidélité prochain point sur l'actu 21h
rester sur arte à l'ours
[Musique]
olivier maintenant détenu depuis huit
mois quelles sont les nouvelles les
nouvelles y en a très peu
malheureusement elles sont coupés de
tout il n'est pas dans un hôtel
capturé avec un téléphone et il peut
nous donner des nouvelles non à votre
avis quelles sont ses conditions de
détention aujourd'hui c'est sûr elles
sont très difficiles parce que les
anciens otages ont pu nous le raconter
qu'il a des conditions de vie qui sont
très rudimentaires et très dur j'espère
vraiment de tout mon coeur qui qui
ressent notre énergie de moi j'essaye de
faire de mon mieux le suivre tout
simplement pour qu'ils m'entendent parce
que c'est ça mon travail c'est la france
et le mali où la france ou le mali qui
vont libérer olivier g pas ce pouvoir de
libérer mais par contre j'ai le devoir
de mobilisation je ne l'abandonnerai pas
je ne laisserai pas
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
c'est un coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité